oui j'ai décidé en fait de prendre la
parole parce que je vois tout un tas
d'inhumanité de chaque côté je trouve ça
insupportable de qu'on traite les gens
dans thiva que moi je suis pas anti
vaccins à la base j'ai fait tous mes
vaccins etc mais je suis pas pour ce
vaccin et quand j'entends des trucs
immonde où on doit dire que les antilles
vague se doivent crever en réanimation
que c'est bien fait s'ils peuvent plus
aller au restaurant que ça donne le
droit de priver des libertés qu'on est
là pour excuser moi le terme les
emmerder ça m'a révolté j'ai deux fils
je vois que là on fait de la delà de la
du forcing pour faire vacciner les
gamins moi je suis journaliste je suis
mère de famille je regarde les chiffres
de draps vigilante les chiffres de verre
ce qu'est la pharmaco vigilance aux
états unis et je suis désolé alors voilà
je sais très bien l'argument du docteur
alexandre qui va me dire que j'y connais
rien en arn messager mais voilà je me
suis renseigné
à pour moi le vaccin non seulement c'est
un échec mais en plus pour moi le tout
vaccinal ce n'est pas la solution
aujourd'hui il ya trois mille huit cents
personnes en réanimation
la majorité sont des gens vaccinés la
plupart des gens les 85% des personnes
les plus 80% des personnes aux plus de
85 ans 45% sont des gens qui souffrent
malheureusement d'obésité donc mais rien
du tout alors c'est le monde entier qui
s'est trompé parce que la france
je vais vous dire je suis je suis pour
la liberté de sa finale vous avez décidé
en votre âme et conscience de vous faire
vacciner malgré tous les effets
secondaires qui ont été qui ont été
listés un cccd vous allez faire alors
après la avec le post vaccinale à bâle
au travail parce que maintenant je suis
pas soumise mais je suis suis pas
soumise mais pour moi c'est une honte et
puis surtout enfin je vois des trucs sur
les réseaux sociaux mais qui me font
bouillir doug bouillir mais d'une
inhumanité
horrible mais jean franchement je vous
dis honnêtement j'en ai chialé j'en ai
chialé ou à mes gosses ça fait ça fait
deux ans qu'ils se portent le mas sur la
tronche là on me demande de les tester
tous les deux jours avec un truc dans
l'est alors qu'ils ne sont même pas
malade et qu'il ne risque strictement
rien pour moi c'est de la maltraitance
des gamins qui ne souffre pas faut quand
même relativiser le taux de létalité du
co lead il est beaucoup moins importants
que d'autres maladies et ça vous pourrez
pas dire le contraire donc à un moment
donné arrêté et en quoi tout ça justifie
qu'on prive de liberté tout un tas de
gens qu'on les traite comme de la merde
et qu'on les empêche d'aller moi je suis
pas une folle je suis pas une anti fades
je crois en la médecine mois ci avait
pas eu la médecine je n'aurais pas eu d
enfant je n'aurais pas aimé enfants donc
un moment falloir arrêter moi j'ai voulu
aller dans ces manifestations pour voir
si effectivement c'était des fachos si
c'était des débiles si c'était des
machins s'il n'y a pas de ça en
manifestation des jeunes ou reconnus bah
oui quelques-uns ils voulaient squash
pas acheter une star donc voilà bah ils
m'ont dit bravo je vois la g pardon
jacques une star ici c'est matthieu
delormeau oui non mais voilà ils m'ont
dit bravo mais je vous le dis
honnêtement j'ai fait en loucedé les
manifestations je me suis pas du tout
affiché sur les réseaux sociaux j'en
suis à ma 12e manifestation parce que
j'ai vu le tournant que ça prenait et en
plus j'ai vu que les mesures sanitaires
j'ai trouvé complètement débile parce
que quand on vous dit qu'il faut manger
vous pouvez aller manger dans un
restaurant et que vous restez assis
parce que si vous êtes debout vous
contaminer davantage sachant que
maintenant on sait que ce vaccin vous
permet d'être contaminés et de et de
transmettre un moment là on va voir la
déclaration d'oran riquet dans un
instant on n ont pas saisi géré a dit
n'être pas du tout d'accord avec eux non
en fait je moi j'entends et en fait je
la comprends enfin je comprends
l'exaspération je comprends que les gens
soient au bord de la crise de nerfs
parce que ça c'est très long ça fait
deux ans maintenant mais malgré tout je
continue à croire en la vaccination moi
j'ai effectivement ulcos vide alors que
je suis trois fois à vacciner je n'ai eu
aucun symptôme donc j'estime que
peut-être andrieu danser aucun ce
peut-être mais peut-être pas devancer
andre ulcos vide j'ai eu entre lui et
alors je me suis fait soigner avec de
l'ivermectine est de l'asie trop micinn
c'est la première fois c'est la première
maladie ou audio aux gens on ne soigne
pas les gens on leur dit prenez du
doliprane et quand vous n'êtes en
détresse respiratoire vous vous
retrouvez nos mesures je suis désolé moi
je suis à vous avez ri qui vont vous
irez vous avez vous avez d'aegeri
comment alors alors j'ai pris de la
citrouille messine et de l'ivermectine
il a fait baisser ma charge virale et je
m'en suis sorti parce que j'ai vu que ça
commence à aller sur mes bronches et
c'est donc j'avais pas envie de me
retrouver en détresse respiratoire
donc j'ai pris ces médicaments
médicaments qui cela dit existe depuis
des années qu'ils ne sont pas qui ne
sont pas quand vous voulez aujourd'hui
qui ne sont pas remboursés par la
sécurité sociale parce que moi mais a
fait payer je m'en fiche j'ai dépensé 30
dates c'est pas grave chez j'ai plus de
trucs mais je suis désolé c'est la
première maladie où les gens ne soigne
pas on ne soigne pas les gens alors que
voler mais qu'est ce que votre corps
bien docteur alors alors c'est pas vrai
qu'on soit une pas les gens on à
diminuer la mortalité due qu'aux vide
par deux grâce à l'oxygène à très haut
débit et grâce à la dexaméthasone qui
est impuissant aux corticoïdes quoi pour
lui une fois qu'ils sont arrivés vers
médine on a démontré dans le monde
entier il l'inde vient de décider de ne
plus donner des réalités on a montré
dans le monde entier l'ivermectine
régatant hélas aucune efficacité dans le
candidat s'il y avait une efficacité de
l'ivermectine vous imaginez bien que
tous les médecins qui sont pas des
pourris les médecins ont prescrit à tous
de l'ivermectine mais ça ne marche pas
bien avec angoisse crise est là mais ça
ne marche pas là ça fait la file
minorité à celle alors en plus sur des
médicaments si vous aviez regardé avec
votre médecin ce qui s'est passé parce
que l'asie trop me signer l'ivermectine
sûr remboursés à 100% donc vous devriez
vainement fait comme ils n'ont pu le
doubler président comme ils ont pu le
rendez vous de définir les pharmacies
voulez vous payez vous les font payer
comme le chikungunya est ce que l on
peut dire un mot de l'orchestré du
vaccin aridi oui le vaccin pression' en
contrôle qu'ovide n'entraîne pas une
protection à 100% être le vaccin contre
la variole vous avez entendu ce qu'a dit
le professeur comme il avait joué un
mauvais match que nous avons un vaccin
qui n'est pas à la hauteur comment du
vaccin contre la variole contre les
vaccins qui protège à 100% on a une
efficacité qui est pas très loin de
celle qu'on a contre la grippe danse
avec la wii mais la grippe tue fait pas
tous les trois mois non tu devras en
disant c'est déjà pas mal à aimer van de
veegaete wasquehal site est obligatoire
je veux pas c'est par la grille n'avait
pas à la hauteur des meilleurs vaccins
qui est à peu près à la hauteur du
vaccin contre la grippe on aimerait bien
avoir un vaccin qui protège petit tour
sur maps et on l'a pas